welcome to this video playing our pizza
rubit saw from from the netherlands okay
again i forgot to play the dutch shell I
got this Dutch request may be here I can
do something else maybe the Queen's
onion already played that something
something different hmm yeah I still
large that give the check okay Jess or
maybe just keep it simple him what to
play with c4 I could have played this
immediately right I could have played
see Han immediately but ok I can still
do it now Oh interesting
hmm this is a funny kind of structural
change looks a bit like a like a
hedgehog but they're the dark squared
Bishop have been traded and some other
pieces as well so i have i have less
pieces than usual which should be quite
ok for black you have less space so less
pieces normally means less trouble um if
I yes I want to block on the dark
squares possibly get the night to e6 hmm
I wonder should he play be four it's
doing something entirely different maybe
he wants to put the knight on d5 but the
big difference is a knight on d5 I can
always just take yeah I'm still night f5
Queen c7 is not worrying me too much I
have g6 all the time and that's this is
curious can I just if I just take it and
play 94 essence is just good maybe but I
can I can delay that I don't need to
take right away maybe it's better to to
not take right away because after ctx he
has Bishop a six and those kind of ideas
and I really don't see something great
for him now I can basically basically
take them at any given time
an end game night against this Bishop
could be very promising we're just rope
c8 okay you want know how to see going
for I have a hard time to understand is
he our weight on the sea has Quincy aid
Quincy at Quincy at 97 okay maybe allow
a lower rook c5 maybe wants to play
rookie three or something but this is
hardly ever working okay now take 94 c
takes 90 54 bishop a6 rook c5 this is
why I went a fire first
okay yeah look a five so that be four is
not so is taking interesting okay maybe
just hear me hmm how to play
hmm it's not it's not really dangerous
or anything the rubric g3 yours things
like that just thinking how to how to
play against this optimally may be here
and Queen F for the right moment maybe
he can play 27 I let's just cover that
hmm g6 maybe Justin simply playing g6 I
don't want to have the Queen on f6 all
the time
yeah wonder isn't the King g7 locate
shade the h4 even something that I can
use I mean 11 point is that this night
bishop on these three is just a dummy my
night however might have some role in
the in the in the play so Queen there
for now or something more aggressive but
this is good right isn't this good the
trade is certainly good for me and how
is he avoiding it efore is hanging
after the trade it takes a for the pawn
on f4 takes away important squares
especially III so wiki 8 will attack the
upon in a very awkward moment the Queen
trade is certainly beneficial for me
okay so it's going with this there's
some way to play here exploit you know
this probably not let's take and no
maybe this preparing a form okay so he
managed he blocks this if I go here what
about the rook trade is this beneficial
time morning chula rook p8 hook page
three okay i'm trading rooks
he's tied to the b3 porn but maybe his
King can come all the way to see 3f for
text ex-king edge to King do some King
entry i'm going to e5 and no i can take
out just f3 was check check what am I
doing here took me took me ages to just
grab this blundered porn I was somehow a
bit stunned that g3 was was coming
because I didn't really expect the move
and write yourself it was just pondering
a bond now you porn you porn should
check should win but I can also get the
deep on check in addition check check
these pawns were made for walking ok
maybe not the jack easiest way to do it
to put a sufficient way white forfeits
on time sure i'm not i'm not sure about
this i mean this whole middle game here
after we got to this it it's something
that white must proceed with with some
caution as the bishop is really a very
very uninspiring piece will never attack
anything in blacks campers everything is
on dark squares and they have the the
great knight on d4 so it's not not very
attractive already but i don't think
that this helps very much this rookie 3
business I don't think so groups Quincy
8 given by the comp not sure ah
interesting move I see yeah i was
thinking about this before i thought
okay well you would just retreat the
Queen anyway but then a four is a good
point very good point a takes be I might
have the immediate c4 and this is a
strong porn interesting way to play
computer however once I do this just go
Queen c7 trying to regain the pawn yeah
Black is fine anyway I thought this is
also ok it's nothing nothing bad yeah
here I was unsure the computer wants to
play age 6 also not bad actually h6 King
age 7 and GC
but I was thinking that I should make
sure that I'm not tied to the just
having porn all the time and the trade
is so something like that it's not very
very attractive I have ideas like that I
can also put pressure on your form the
King can possibly run it's just a great
night against a very bad bishop this is
this is so this is also a problem the
computer wants to keep the rooks on the
board interesting and I wasn't sure it's
clear that that black is better but it's
not clear if black can win that is an
entirely different matter the capture is
probably a mistake maybe a losing
mistake going but what happens if he
plays this I go f form
it's interesting this is this year just
giving them the line that stock fish is
giving King f2 g5g for with a cleared
for black but can you win no probably
not what be right is just shuffling and
still the computer is giving black
almost a pawn of an advantage okay this
is not realistic this is a draw I
probably want to keep the pawn structure
flexible first and get get down maybe
not quite clear if I can win it's better
of course but can you win different
different matter okay well thanks for
watching